[Music]
three two one action action hey guys
welcome back to off-the-record or we
talk about whatever we want and we got
hi how's it going what's up my fellow
sea men hey guys you know what I miss
y'all man I wish I really liked you guys
you know you guys are like my YouTube
buddies but even beyond YouTube I always
tell people I don't [ __ ] with a lot of
people in the space so it's like you
guys David
keV on stage and his his squad [ __ ] with
a lot of people don't feel special
anymore he's right though there's so few
cool people though yeah not compared to
the spectrum of how it works
Steve I wanted I feel bad you two guys
have been around actual like youtubers
because for us I think we've been around
the Asian YouTube which is its own
bubble yeah and that's it like I don't
do the [ __ ] VidCon thing the playlist
thing like we did it yeah it was like me
like with huge issues right you guys the
shows that we did all musicians dancers
yeah but it's still Asian YouTube which
is like its own little bubble yeah it's
it's own little like I feel like even a
lot of the Asian youtubers aren't
invited to like playlist and VidCon I
don't really see a whole lot of it we
never work yeah or maybe they just don't
go oh but then you're right they're like
our idea of YouTube is kind of a bubble
though the rest of YouTube is a bunch of
dumbasses it's all pretty quickie though
you know they're very quick yeah Huggy
do people even know I always feel like
it was um different like almost like
high school right well you have your
different pockets of groups and cliques
and you know be every single career in
like every really
everything cuz even when I was working
in the hospital everything felt like
high school like the horse isn't a
doctor isn't [ __ ] and you're in a place
where people are considered smart right
so that's what you have to realize is
that the entire world is equally dumb
like no matter where you go the same
childish [ __ ] still leaks to the top
and so that's why we have a Congress
that has a ton of [ __ ] men and women
who have NDA's for sexual rights and we
pay for that we subsidize that you can
look it up
so so even in our the peeler the places
where we're supposed to be the most
respected and all this [ __ ] they're
degenerates that's why I think all
humans are stupid [ __ ] animals that
have computer brains so I agree right
cuz I used to think like am I am I the
weird one for like hating everybody or
like or thinking that you know a lot of
people just don't get my sense of humor
or like is it wrong of me to to not like
people for not being on my level right
but then I realized you know it's not
that everybody's stupid cuz like that
that sounds dumb it's that I'm just
smarter it's meaning I like your
positive it's mean right if you say oh
the world is stupid but then it's like
the world's not stupid we're just better
see whoa I say the same thing but I'm
including myself in the world when I say
everyone and humans are stupid obviously
I'm not talking about everyone else I'm
thinking about me included right because
we contradict ourselves all the time
we're hypocrites like that's just a
human trait you can't wait eat your [ __ ]
yeah never get tired of like oh no I
love it
human experience like just being a human
but sometimes I'm just saying a lot of
words I'm gonna be a kitty right now and
then you likey
Oh it'll be owl like living [ __ ] owl
myself get out
but now sometimes like a like I'm top
I'm referring to like when I get into my
dark thoughts yeah realm where I'm like
it's just too hard like it's just hard
it's a like what's the trigger usually
for something like that usually she's
sitting in her Tesla she's like she's in
a comfortable warm yeah like when it
comes to situations where it's like oh
[ __ ] I gotta I got a deal with like a
family issue or something where I'm like
there's a lot of work power to be is if
if they were dead no not nothing when
you get there how do you get if you have
a problem at that problem if this thing
is a trigger then you just want the
trigger to go away you want to pull a
trigger and eliminate it suppose I see
supports like my dad's gonna yell at me
when he gets home today from Fred come
on from school that's so I hope me guys
on the way whoa it's not because I think
we've all been in that like that
relationship that you where you feel
trapped in the relationship and you kind
of talk in the home and you're like oh
man like like I don't want her to die
but damn if she just died oh like in a
plane actually nothing like [ __ ] I love
that what about the 225 other souls on
board the plane oh yeah on the flight
yeah yeah right yeah well the only
person on the flight may be better if
this person was gone I get it yeah I
don't get specific cuz you want to avoid
the conflict for me it's the opposite I
end up thinking about myself so you want
a guy that's what I mean like I get
really dark sometimes yeah but you wanna
die I think all of us want to die yeah
I'm like if I was just no no I know what
really it gets it gets fun because every
that you're at this stage where you're
like aware of it right because most
people they're just reacting they're not
aware of that but once you realize how
funny it
that's when things get super
entertaining and that's when you go
towards the cringe yeah once you really
never felt that it's like let me go to
war the cringe let me see how this
person operates like I'm walking toward
threatening situations cuz I'm like I
want to see what happens you love you
love mafia man once you realize that
we're all like evolved from apes and
we're all just making things up the
fastest it gets really fun okay so this
is the thing I think there's two ways
people go where it can get really scary
or really entertaining right and that's
how we view reality because some people
their world crumbles and then they go to
fear or for me I go wait I can control
my reality this is [ __ ] hilarious so
let's go and see what type of
perceptions people have of their world
and which when you could break that down
okay I'm getting a little nerdy here but
that [ __ ] gets me [ __ ] excited as
hell I'm like I can see what this [ __ ]
is looking at and he has no idea that's
why we love the James Cage rights of the
world even the way that we provide
meaning to things that are meaningless
right like why do we celebrate birthdays
it's such a stupid thing this is my
culture [ __ ] this is everything
to me yeah yeah like what people like
what do people identify with
it's funny how do you put yourself into
this this comes from my neighborhood
[ __ ] this water yeah I take
pride in this ship or even like this is
my culture as seaweed he wants the
Kansas City Chiefs win the Superbowl
you're from Kansas join we won I won I
know how stupid that is but yet I
partake in that and I'd love to be
brainwashed kind of going off of what
TIFF was saying but the complete
opposite it's like you start thinking
about like okay what if you weren't here
right but I always I always think like
[ __ ] I know everybody's gonna die so
then it's kind of like all this shit's
pointless yeah as well have fun you know
some people go it's pointless what's the
reason of lose the point it depends on
perspective right right the thing is at
the end of the day you have to create
your own meaning you can't wait for
meaning to come to you so if you're
searching for meaning what's the meaning
of live what's the whatever right you
spend the time living thinking of what
it means and then you die but we put the
meaning of life is that we give meaning
to life literally everything that
matters to us we created and that's me
we have the power to manufacture this
life right
when you can harness that that's when it
becomes really really fun hey happy
birthday TIF isn't any kind of special
for you because it's your birthday it
means nothing but isn't it kind of just
it deals it's good feel good because you
put meaning into it you're like oh
[ __ ] that girl with the map how she's
just like redid the map cuz she's like
what's the point like it's all pointless
yeah it's all screwed all the like the
borderlines and [ __ ] yeah that's true I
love it though I love it I love ok it
gets like this like people don't realize
that the world that they're living in
isn't real meaning like they think
everything is a [ __ ] fact there are
thoughts they don't question it yep and
they think you're crazy they think their
emotional attachment to physical things
are real versus the same physical thing
gives a million different emotional
alright true true yeah spoken like a man
is building a pool in his backyard what
does that mean it gives me a lot of
emotional I know yeah stresses me out
Wow so yeah there you go no but I was
just in Vegas right when you're looking
at all the [ __ ] casinos and all this
[ __ ] I'm just going I'm so glad this is
here and not a [ __ ] boring ass desert
you know what we're providing fun things
to do because if this didn't exist it's
like what am i doing right now
so raining or I could be on you could be
a person that's like well the casinos
are designed to guarantee the law so
statistically it's like a lose-lose
situation please never no no cuz the
point is there's some you know like
there is a placebo effect right if the
placebo is gonna [ __ ] work and I can
brainwash myself to cure myself of
cancer shut the [ __ ] up and let me
believe it yeah cuz then I'll just take
the sugar pill and cure myself I've at
the very least at least you're making
the most out of whatever time you got
yeah even if it's just all in your head
well even if it is literally on your
brain cancer you have a limit wait
that's all in your head
I think we're a perception of life is
all weird the same thing until he said
that we're like all right least I would
like oh he flipped it on you did you
guys know that an asteroid that was big
enough to wipe out the human race
yep just past earth like five days ago
yeah and we didn't even know about it
until it was already too late because
they're probably not trying to warn us
and get us all scared yeah that's how I
did someone else save us please respect
your boundaries you're not on your own
involvement no but no but the point is
is that we didn't even know life is so
fragile it could have ended right there
yeah all could be have been gone already
that's what I'm saying man I feel like
cuz people I've been accused of not
worrying enough about things cuz I just
could you not woken up god dammit i love
how chill you are about everything yeah
cuz he hears I feel like man we could we
could literally like a car could come
flying through this wall right now and I
could die yeah like what really matters
the thing is people are trying to find
out you're so bad at working people are
trying this is the thing about today is
people are trying to control your
reactions and how you cope so what I see
is a symbolism of I don't give a [ __ ]
optimistic person right what would Tim
do right so in a crisis do you want
people [ __ ] screaming like a little
[ __ ] or do you want what would Tim do
what would Tim do maybe Tim will cause a
fire let's chill bro it's a it's a it's
a fire let's chill and just [ __ ] see
there we go Oh God
let's go get a burger buddy that we're
trying to bring on to JK news
so he's MARSOC which is Marine Raider
and he said after he went through all
the special obstacles at his first
deployment I think was in Afghanistan
the first time they were he got into
engagement with the other people and
they're shooting back
he was like his [ __ ] bullets flying
bricks exploding Wow his platoon
sergeant as I called the [ __ ] down and
he's like oh hey I'm gonna have to be
calm in this circumstance even though
it's now it's just crazy that the same
same circumstance depending on your
perspective some people just look at
like
he says produced art you can pretty much
call his girlfriend just have a regular
conversation why are you shooting guns
he's all like Albion I'll be a dinner
pop all be there late that's called my
kid relate a little bit to that cuz like
now that I've like that's the most
extreme version of that but like now
when I'm starting to feel anxious and
stuff I take a second til I kind of
analyze like Oh anxiety is making me my
body reacted this way and then like once
I acknowledge it then it starts like
dissipating oh my god but it has to
start with the belief that you can
control it because if you have the
belief that you cannot control it then
you're bounded by that belief yeah for
the people out there that's why there's
a there's a there's a battle right now
I'm controlling it like being okay with
it yeah yeah or yeah acknowledging that
you may be relaxed yeah to it or
whatever it is there's there's different
schools of thought right but people are
fighting over the belief so some people
will say you you have to just it just
hits you and there's nothing you can do
other people will say yeah it comes but
then I can manage it I can deal with it
I can transform it and if there's other
people that are just like okay well I
can relax into it but there's no real
one objective truth to how you should
deal with anxiety or the definition of
it I think that's why it's different so
many people watching this are thinking
well okay so Steven John you guys are
all saying like well nothing matters so
[ __ ] it but but so how do you how do you
give them some kind of motivation I
don't go to hell mother [ __ ] I'm just
kidding I think that you can control the
meaning and purpose based off of what
you want but first you got to figure out
what you want if you don't know what you
want and you're searching for someone
else to fill that claim for you or that
answer then you end up living life for
other people or their expectations and I
think that's the hardest thing to do is
because it goes right back down to not
wanting to be accountable or not wanting
to risk failing so it all it always
comes back to your personal experience
and defending your ego or like not
wanting to fail not wanting to be hurt
being scared things like that people
don't want to admit like I'm afraid to
choose a purpose in life because if the
purpose doesn't come through I let
myself down
that's why not everyone opens businesses
themselves right like it's like I'd
rather have an employee mindset
or I just kind of let somebody else make
those it's easier Asians I can check
in/check easier and then I look forward
to my weekend but really what is my life
mean and that's when [ __ ] gets hard and
I mean it to be fair some people are
cool with it which is great what is my
life mean then they're fine but if they
are while they're going through that
like it'd be something else my goal was
to let's say be a manager at a
restaurant right and I love working with
my coworkers
this was my favorite restaurant I love
the food that they do then that's
purpose mm-hmm it's not really a boss
employee entrepreneur thing it's really
being in line with the thing that you
set out to do
yeah versus reacting to the world yeah
cuz it's fulfilling now that same person
being the manager is like man I wanted
to be a singer and then they're just
like forever like lonely and depressed
yeah and then there's teachers out there
who [ __ ] love it I know because I met
them like they were my teachers
sometimes sometimes but like sometimes
they were also jaded people who [ __ ]
hated that they're teaching now because
they feel like they failed so it's just
whatever gives you meaning is all yeah
like what are you passionate about what
do you want yeah and I think just people
understanding that they can control and
create their own life I think that once
you can really see and understand that
and really believe it it's [ __ ] left
but I do think that it is scary though
because we're trained and taught
throughout life to just follow orders so
we're not really taught to think for
ourselves and that's why I mean think
about it for the for the longest period
of time for humans we've had religion
telling us what to do we had the
government telling us what to do we had
the school system doing that right where
a degree tells you what to do right so
you didn't have to think and make too
many decisions for yourself so now
you're all of a sudden expected to do
that like people are more a theist now
people are choosing their own career
path now your own even your own person
that you marry and people used to choose
that the community is to choose that
your parents used to choose it for you
right now you can hear anybody
apparently basically the
overwhelmingness of the responsibility
and choice I think is also contributing
to people's confusion because in the
past it's like
so much control shopping thing to write
when you have too many options you're
just like go pick anything not me I'm
like what's the cheapest one the
cheapest one that my wife won't get
really mad about yeah yes
Oh when you get the cheesecake bag you
open that big-ass menu like there's a
big a skinny fit chicken pot pie is that
good that's part G's cake factory see
500 calories thinking all right you know
I go off the kiddie menu and I get
there's a little steak they cut up a
little steak with the asparagus and it's
really good soon so see life is like the
Cheesecake Factory menu barred
immediately opens the menu in points and
the rest of us are like I would need a
couple minutes think I want to read
everything like everything that they
have and I'm like how come the skinny
salad is 650 calories but then when I go
to the [ __ ] superfood salad it's
2,000 calories what do you guys do that
poor salad it's like this big that's
what it is what is it like Kate's in
butter and [ __ ] what the [ __ ] they do
it's cheesecake bits I work there no I
just your answer like an insider bro I'm
just making it up as I go just like I do
in life Russy hey dressing cheese
croutons and the bacon bits yeah well
that's what makes it delicious well we
all could agree to disagree just like we
do in life because you can is truly the
cheese speaker well I disagree to agree
yeah and you know what's even funnier is
that I go to Cheesecake Factory I'd say
probably once a month I never have had
cheesecake for three in ten years and
doesn't that say a lot about life I
think she's cake at Cheesecake Factory
you know what I mean you're not living
life to the fullest potential wait you
said you go once a month and you have
been in ten years where'd you just say
no I haven't had a cheesecake Eternia oh
you haven't had a cheesecake cheesecake
factory so here I am Here I am late
[ __ ] hypocrite once again jacking is
talking about how we should all live our
lives and yet I go cheesecake cheesecake
history and I'm scared guys I'm [ __ ]
scared cheesecake
you're just a human no because I know
what it can do to your body I love
cheesecake [ __ ] it
I'll work it off later instead I'm being
feared who goes to a Cheesecake Factory
and not get the cheesecake then I Ivan
my long time I go there for dinner no no
I get it to go I get this I walk to I do
and then I never get to it I want to but
the portions are so big I can't I can't
I said no room for differ dessert a menu
then take a slice to go see you gotta
wait until that red clicker goes off
right but then when that red clicker
thing goes off and you're about to get
your table be [ __ ] ready yeah you be
ready then okay that's when preparation
meets opportunity and you're ready to
order at the Cheesecake Factory when
your little [ __ ] thing goes off to
get deep on your ass but that's kind of
what we do here I'm gonna be ready so
you ain't gotta get ready
oh dude I'm gonna do a TED talk on that
I would steal your [ __ ] life is like a
Taco Bell oh it's all the same [ __ ] but
it's still great different shapes
different tastes favorite same place
yeah human being different shapes same
ingredients and we're happy hour is
always disappointing alcoholic no and
I'm like why do you want happy hour I
know I this is kind of a thing you so
much she's gonna talk about talk about
talk about all you talk about the ones
that serve alcohol be like hey it's
happy alright now I'm like what does
that mean yeah and we give you a skills
drink and like that's not happy I talk
about Cantina there they have they have
alcohol you Del Taco you gotta [ __ ]
up your game homie yeah
[Music]